on money we're focusing on financial
lessons from the pandemic
one in four adult americans have had
trouble paying their bills since the
coronavirus pandemic began
and one-third have been forced to dip
into their savings or retirement
accounts
in order to make ends meet cbs news
business analyst jill schlesinger is
here with
how to get your finances in order during
this difficult time jill good morning
you say jill that in times like this
it's best to go back to basics
how do you build a strong financial
foundation
in a moment like this well everything
starts with
cash flow and we learned that back in
march and that means
you've got to understand how much money
is coming in but probably more
importantly
how much money is going out and where
you are spending your money
and i think this is incredibly important
because when people were really freaked
out
and maybe sidelined from the labor force
they had to go back and say okay how
much on food
everything else i can figure it out and
also one
huge lesson from the pandemic is we need
to live
digital lives we know that people got
stimulus checks faster when they had
filed their taxes electronically
we know people moved all around the
country and so bill paying
paying those electronically made so much
more sense so
go digital get it get on it when there's
another round of stimulus you will be
happier to have had
those digital footprints in place jill
if you're having trouble paying your
bills right now
what do you do well i think that there
is a
really important lesson of the last
eight months
and that is that you've got to
understand you can negotiate
and this is true whether you're dealing
with a big landlord a utility company
a cable provider these folks on the
other end of the line
they actually don't want to punish you
they want to help you out so you
don't want to go dark if you don't ask
you're not going to get
so we want you to do that the other part
of this that's become quite important is
you can seek the help of professionals
maybe there's a tax preparer
a certified financial planner and in
extreme cases
clearly there are some people who need
to consider bankruptcy
but remember those bankruptcy fees
whether it's the lawyers fees and the
process it can be expensive
and it can damage your credit score for
up to seven years
as we mentioned before jill a recent
study found that a third of adults
have dipped into their savings or their
retirement accounts
what do you do to replenish those
accounts ultimately
i think americans did an amazing job of
really building up their savings during
the pandemic we know the savings rate
went up to over
30 percent in the spring as of
yesterday's gdp report we found out
that's more than
halved and so what we want to try to do
is as you said
get those numbers up again why because
we don't know what's going to happen
over the next three six or nine months
so you want to try to automate your
savings as much as possible
this is true if you are especially if
you are employed right now and you've
got the ability to do it
automate it set up a transfer
automatically from a checking account to
a savings or investment account
and one note about those retirement
savings i know
that there are the the ability to borrow
and withdraw from your retirement
account is available through the end of
the year
be very careful it took you a long time
to get
those funds built up if it's your last
option sure you can do it
but try not to touch those retirement
accounts all right jill schlesinger
thank you jill